hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to 50 questions in five
minutes I have 50 questions that have
been assembled from you guys that I have
not seen I also have a shock collar on
my neck now here's how this gonna work
and here's how this shock collar makes
sense I have only five minutes to answer
50 questions that gives me 6 seconds per
question in addition to reading the
question itself if I answer a question
in time I'm all good but if I don't
answer a question either because I can't
answer it I don't know the answer or I
don't want to answer it I have to shock
myself and then every time I have to
shock myself I have to increase the
value of this shock it goes from 1 to 15
and at 15 it is a deadly shock indeed
and if I don't manage to answer all 50
questions then I have to shock myself
increasingly for every question that I
did not answer all right if you're ready
I'm ready 3 2 1 go
which ego is your favorite uh wharfs s
what do you do to tackle procrastination
um I tell myself I'm an [ __ ] and I
just get to work when you let you get
married or as she is strong independent
dog oh I let her get married if she
found true love but I'd have to test out
that boy dog No are you a virgin no
where are thy feet right here should I
drop my math class no joke seriously
bathing it how can you drop your math
class are you in high school if you can
if you are in high school that means you
can't drop it if you're in college then
go for it if it's not pretending to your
major is water technically soup no do
you remember the faces of your victims
who are my victims I know what is the
lowest note you can sing your voice
pretty deep so I think you can hit
really low nose
what it's the highest out you can reach
what is the source of your power and
where can I get it from the man
worshipping the moon monsters where do
babies come from it comes from penis
going into vagina it's ejaculating sperm
do you ever think you might be too hard
on yourself talking about a shock collar
who killed barbar I did
if one synchronized swimmer drowns
during a show do the others drown as
well only if they're dedicated enough
what's your first sona I don't have one
god increasing difficulty how do you get
over someone you never even dated get
over your own ego how do you get so
uncommon please Vic ah
when's the last time you showered and
why yesterday because I worked out for
two hours
you live in Cali right yes does
Lightning McQueen buy life insurance or
car insurance ah okay are you okay dude
no I'm wearing this shock collar and
shocking myself for her video views is
Pete in the policies no it's not where
is the proboscis hop if you'll observe
right here this is the proboscis what
would it be your perfect day me looking
at a mirror with a dinner that I made if
you had to estimate it how much pasta
could you fit in your house yeah a
million boxes what's your favorite
flavor profile are you a sweet sky or
savory of salty I don't believe in
flavor profiles I think they were made
up
government for a nutritional guideline
that doesn't exist can you be my senpai
already em you'll see have you ever read
a fanfic every day are you planning on
moving out of LA every time thought
about a million times I'm so indecisive
I kind of hate myself is life really
worth living that's not for me to decide
my life is maybe your assistance how
long is your tech do you have a big P
nor God what does it mean that I shot
but I'm refusing to answer that question
not out of because I have a small Peter
my peen or is humongous and yeah
whatever are you proud of Ethan no do
you handle thoughts how do you handle
thoughts uncle I'm sorry what is the
most expensive thing you've broken my
sanity why do men have nipples what are
they for why are they there why every
human is a genetic template starting
with female male being male is is a
change that happens to the fetus and the
womb if you whatever it's the Y
chromosome
because we can produce them it's runs by
[ __ ] how does one get a girlfriend I
ask how deep is an anus it goes out your
mouth what time is it on the moon two
moons time is a social construct there's
no people on the moon sir there's no
time let's see how do you feel about the
minor prevent backlash about doing
videos your way instead of doing the
videos the audience's way who gives a
[ __ ] and you do videos that make you
happy
people don't like it then people are
gonna watch it mark what's the happiest
you've ever felt the first day I got
chica if you could be friends with the
character Brenda game who would you
choose myself in a fan game because I'm
awesome let's see can you fit your whole
fist around oh I need foot by itself I
quit lip I bit my lip Brevard I think
I'm gonna bleed it's okay keep going
if you had eight hands would you grab
your significant others but with all the
Indians are at the same time or with
each aah Sam look your favorite thing
about Lily I don't know convenient food
everywhere Boozer ass ass would you ever
rose to Bacchus yes would you ever read
how your hair grades go no no you got
this stuff oh I got the stuff all right
baby
is that it how I punch myself in the
face I am bleeding Oh hmm that hurt and
that hurt pretty much all of it hurt but
I answered the questions as best I could
this has been 50 questions in five
minutes I managed to get through all of
them in the appropriate amount of time
and with the appropriate sanity left
there just blood all over my teeth well
that's what happens when you try to rush
through life like that so just as a
lesson
I only taste blood if you want to see me
do this again with more questions let me
know down in the comments below if you
got more questions that you want me it's
super and that don't involve me punching
myself in my teeth let me know as well
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know you buy this and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye